Hey guys, how's it going? Today it is very cold in Los Angeles. Last week, it was I kid you not
113 degrees and when I was in Anaheim and this here is an iPhone 10 vlog
Guys LA has seasons. Look I just adjusted the color so when I clicked on the sky look how good that looks?
You do look pretty good, that's good a nice shot ready
I'm not looking at the camera. See this is me looking at the camera, and this is me looking at the screen
Cool, let's start this hike
Click me this is the back camera we're hiking up to this mountain. I'm so excited for this drone shot
I've been thinking about this shot whenever I first wrote the vo for this video, and I was like
this is what I want. And this morning I woke up
it was raining I was like Jenna no the shot
So that's the hill, huh?
Right there
He's in samarkand the hill. We're zoomed in by success. I'll race you there. Yeah, okay
You just wanna escape go I just tried
You've got back
So the shot I'm looking for is I'm holding up the phone, and then you're gonna like fly away
It'll be a close-up shot of it. Okay. We don't have much time, cuz it's getting dark
This is my first vlog on the iPhone ten
She let me have it because she's occupied
I am occupied I can't take my eyes off the drone.
Alright we're coming in coming in coming in Oh god I have to switch it
Like look how fast
I almost lost a finger
I'm so cold. I'm shaking
We're walking down
We're gonna get dinner at Third street Promenade, check out the apple store where I slept outside for the Iphone 6
That was probably the craziest thing I think that I have ever done. Although
I have stayed up so late editing iPhone videos this week that I think I felt better sleeping outside
Waiting for the phone that I did shooting and editing all of these videos this week
I don't do well if I don't get a lot of sleep, and I don't eat well
and I've just been like snacking and drinking coffee and yerba mate a
We gotta go
It's Trivia I don't know I wasn't in service
I'm cold, please hurry
Jenna, playing Trivia
Yes! I've never got pass four
Low-light optical image stabilization
Let's talk about, okay, guess not, bye Jen
Okay, this is the line, this is it? There's people. They did put them in the middle. Yes, that's right
Yes, they moved us from over here, to over here.
Everybody wait until tomorrow morning, it's gonna be the best day. And there's the apple store tomorrow.
Jenna, we're not camping out
Tomorrow morning will be the release on our own time. Oh, I'm so excited you guys remember when we slept out
This is where we slept for over 55 hours
We were here well probably for like 40 we were here, and then they moved us over here
So the best part is in 2010 I said I will never be first in line for an Iphone video
And then here I was 20-
Was that 2014? Is that when we slept out? Um I'm not sure yet so yeah 2014
This is monumental, so you are first in line. I'm first in line. Okay introduce yourself. What's up guys. I'm Jake
I just moved to LA from New York. I got here 10:30 this morning after watching Justine's old video.
I can't believe I'm first in line for the new iPhone
We're just talking about it over here. So, what's your channel? You make Youtube videos as well?
I make Youtube videos
It's like kind of a mix of everything a little bit of vlogs. I do Jiu Jitsu, a little bit of tech videos
I'm just a techie, but I'm not as well-versed as like Justine or marques. Hey, you're first in line
This is monumental. I mean, this is like the 10th anniversary,
Oh, and this is, guys, hold on one sec
She is the one who sold me the wings from the Iphone slow-mo video
Oh my god, this is so great. You're gonna camp out too?
No, thankfully. I've got it pre-ordered, it's in the mail. Nice
But, ya first in line, oh my god I'm so excited
I'm so excited to check out your channel and Justine wait,  while you're filming, she has another great story
Yes, what? Hi, Hi
I- You don't remember but I met you two back in 2010, at the Teen Choice awards
Oh my goodness, from New York I know right. Its so good to see you again, that's awesome
We just got some pizzas to give the people on line and I'm having Jenna film
Becuz I can't have my phone out in line for the people that are waiting for the phone
So I'm hiding the phone, we're gonna go back and we're gonna give them some pizzas
I remember when we was camping out, that getting food was like the best part of the day
and these people are hungry, they need a snack
Oh I was like where did you go? Getting the shot
I already tripped once
Pizza pizza delivery
It sm- you smell so nice like wafting in my in my face with those pizzas
It smells really good. Watch your step
Man, I messed up, I should've got pizza, we should've got pizza
We got like a healthy salmon salad, this is what I want
Okay, I was trying to hide this, clearly
Would you like to hide it in my pants? NO
Alright, we got first in line and what number are you? I don't even know
It doesn't even matter,
but they got pizza , and we are gonna head home, and I'm going to edit this video, and tomorrow morning
the iPhone ten will be released into the world
Okay, bye, bye guys